big win for religious liberty yesterday
at the supreme court the court ruled six
to three in kennedy versus bremerton
school district that the school violated
coach joseph kennedy's rights when it
fired him for kneeling and saying a
private prayer after football games
the biggest takeaway is that religious
freedom is not completely dead in
america
but the second biggest takeaway
and this has been underreported
is that liberals have absolutely no idea
what conservatives actually believe
instantly after the decision came out a
bunch of prominent libs on social media
jumped at what they thought was going to
be conservative hypocrisy you saw a
million variations of well if you think
conservatives should be allowed to pray
privately at school then you probably
think that jews and muslims should be
allowed to do that too right
gotcha
to which all of the conservatives
replied
uh-huh yep sounds good
it wasn't wasn't the first time that
we've seen this kind of thing
we were seeing this liberal disconnect
for weeks after the carson decision from
the supreme court if you think
christian students in maine should be
able to spend their education funding at
christian schools then maybe jews and
muslims should be allowed to spend it at
their own schools huh
huh
uh-huh yeah that's great sounds like a
great idea let's do it
after the dobbs decision you want to ban
abortion huh well maybe we should pass a
law to make men
support the women that they impregnate
what do you think about that
i think that's a great idea where do i
sign up for that i cool let's go let me
co-sponsor that you you don't like gay
marriage huh well if you're such a
defender of marriage what if we made it
harder for straight couples to get
divorced
awesome
right you support the second amendment
huh so uh you think it's fine for black
men to own guns
i do yes
one in four black men in america already
own guns and black rifles and black
people they're both great in my book
the list goes on
and on
it is a huge political weakness for the
libs i think it probably explains in
part why conservatives have been making
such unusual gains in recent years
if you want to defeat your opponent the
first thing that you've got to do is try
to understand
your opponent
right now the conservatives generally
understand what motivates the libs
and the libs don't have even the
foggiest notion of what motivates us i'm
michael knowles this is the mike when
all show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from juan estevas
who says
it's crazy how fast they went from my
body my choice to eugenics
it is it's crazy it's wild it's nuts to
see
but it's not crazy in the sense that
eugenics is the logical conclusion of
that if your politics is just all about
your will and just what you want all the
time and it's not about reason or logic
or morality it's just about what you
want
then eugenics is going to be the obvious
conclusion of that that's not just true
now it's been true throughout all of
human history when you divorce reason
and logic in the moral order from
politics things get ugly real fast
it's not even just the radical libs who
have no idea what conservatives believe
it's even the
squishy conservatives the center left
the former conservatives david frum
david frum who is a speechwriter during
the bush administration he was a vaguely
kind of conservative guy and now he's a
sort of center liberal guy he tweeted
out
after the the kennedy case after the
case
that
vindicated the football coach for
praying privately after the football
games he said supreme court opens way
for rousing chants of allahu akbar
before high school sporting events
ha ha
you conservatives you're gonna because
david frum's idea here is that the
conservatives while they're celebrating
the christian being able to pray
privately after the football games the
chris the conservatives hate muslims and
so if the muslims pray we're we're
really going to hate that right which to
me is not only
false it not only rings false it rings
extremely dated though i suppose it
makes sense coming from from because
from came to prominence during the bush
years and during the bush years it was
at least commonly believed that the
muslims they're our real enemy the
radical islamic extremists they're the
real threat to civilization i suspect
today it feels a little bit different
doesn't it
which group do you think poses a greater
threat to your way of life and to your
kids and to your rights into your
country do you think it's the muslims or
do you think it's the radical leftists
got to tell you these days if i'm saying
what's the most immediate threat look
islam
the muslim groups have been invading the
west since the 7th century so i'm not
saying there's no threat there battle of
lepanto battle of vienna battle of
poitiers there listen this is a
long-standing tradition okay but today
right now in the year of our lord 2022
what poses the greatest threat to me
islam or radical leftism it's radical
leftism no question about that we're
talking about schools i would much
sooner send my child to a madrasa than i
would send him to most woke public
schools because
whatever differences i have with the
muslims on matters of theology
philosophy and the like
at least the muslims aren't going to try
to convince my son he's a little girl
okay
what whatever
disagreements i have with the islamic
world
frankly the the claims that are made by
radical leftism boys are secretly girls
babies aren't really babies we everyone
who built our civilization is evil
there is no god all the claims of of the
radical left are way more dangerous than
what whatever whatever claims are being
made by the muslim world
but people don't quite get that
people don't quite they they really
believe someone like david frum i guess
or the the rest of these guys they
really believe that conservatives we
just hate muslims and it's
it's just not true it's just is it is it
true you ask yourself if you are a
conservative if you're a center right
do you is that is that really what you
think the fear is allahu akbar at at
high schools
a muslim or a jew or something making a
private prayer no i think the far
greater risk to our civilization comes
from
atheism the libs are especially blind on
issues of faith and morals you saw this
yesterday
on the view you know that
that forum of elevated public debate the
view joy behar made the claim that we
are now living because of decisions like
the one yesterday we are now living in a
theocracy
don't we have church uh separation yes
yes and have thomas jefferson there and
alexander hamilton hello yeah uh do we
still have a separation of church and
state here is in the constitution yeah
it's a it's the first amendment
guarantee and we don't seem to have that
anymore well we're in a bureaucracy
right now six of the nine
that was an amazing clip from the view
because nothing they said was true and
everything they said was false and they
managed to fit
many many false and ignorant statements
into about 20 seconds
joy behar says do we still have
separation of church and state
we never had a separation of church and
state that's not real
tuck that one away with the boogeyman
that's never existed
is that still in the constitution it is
not in the constitution there is
right now pull up the constitution full
text of the constitution do a do a
search for separation of church and
state you will not find it
yeah it's in the first amendment the
first amendment has something called the
establishment clause which says that
there won't be a nationally established
church the reason for that at the time
of the ratification of the constitution
is that the states had established
churches
it's not a not a firm separation of
church and state let's get jefferson on
the phone jefferson did use that phrase
one time in a private letter let's get
hamilton on the phone hamilton was not
some great defender of the separation of
church and state because it's not
possible
joy behar says we're living in a
theocracy now
we're not i mean
would that it were so simple
we are living in an extremely religious
increasingly totalitarian state
it has
very extreme moral claims
but it's not it's not a christian
theocracy that's for sure
it's a different kind of religious state
all politics
is in a certain sense theocratic because
everyone's making claims about human
nature and how we're supposed to live
together and what society should look
like and what morality is but the only
difference is that now instead of living
in a christian theocracy or a muslim
theocracy or jewish theocracy we're
living in a theocracy of leftism
in a religious state
of leftism
i don't know if you've seen
rockefeller plaza recently in
rockefeller plaza in new york one of the
most famous scenes in new york
all of the american flags have been
replaced
by gay pride flags
i don't know if you've seen london
recently any photos coming out of london
all of the british flags have been
replaced by
rainbow flags
pride flags
those are moral claims
those are religious claims the religious
claims that men can secretly be women
that's in the new trans pride flag
the religious claim that
men and women are not meant for one
another that the purpose of our bodies
and our sexuality is not to come
together men and women and produce
babies but to just have whatever sex
gives us pleasure whatever sort of
titillates us those are religious maybe
you agree with those religious claims
but they you have to at least admit they
are religious claims
and the state is elevating them the
state is elevating them so much that
we're getting rid of our old flags the
symbol of our nations and replacing them
with the new flags of a liberal empire
based on new liberal international
transnational values that are just as
true in tahiti according to the libs as
they are in our own countries and flags
that stand for morals a certain moral
view that happens to be at odds with the
traditional views of our civilization
it's it's it's theocratic it's extremist
it's totalitarian just not the way that
the libs are pretending that it is and
when things are going haywire like they
are right now you want to protect your
property and your prosperity and your
wealth that's why you got to check out
birch gold right now text knowles to
989898 our nation's authorities are
openly admitting to having completely
missed the flashing red lights of
inflation and this administration's
failed economic policy quote i was wrong
about the path inflation would take
that's what treasury secretary janet
yellen said there have been
unanticipated and large shocks to the
economy that have boosted energy and
food prices and supply bottlenecks that
have affected our economy badly that at
the time i didn't fully understand
that's what the treasury secretary is
saying didn't fully understand there you
have it straight from the horse's mouth
i didn't fully understand now i know
that you are worried about affording
basic necessities in the months to come
food gas shelter but she didn't know she
didn't know it's not her fault goes
without saying you can't trust these
so-called authorities on economic policy
which is why you should invest at least
some of your money in gold and silver
with birch gold group protect your
savings from a highly turbulent economy
by diversifying your 401k or ira into
physical gold it's not too late the best
time to take action was yesterday the
second best time is today text knolls to
98 98 98 get a free info kit on
diversifying and protecting your savings
with precious metals birch gold group
has an a plus rating with better
business bureau countless five star
reviews thousands of satisfied customers
text knowledge to nine eight nine eight
nine eight
get real advice from birch gold today
text knolls to 989898 claim your free no
obligation info kit on protecting your
savings with gold
speaking of foreigners
i've got really bad news i'm sorry i
have to have to report this to you
as a result of the dobbs decision
hundreds of thousands of babies per year
will now be saved from being murdered
that's true and the people of the states
get to
choose their own abortion laws which is
something that's a right that they have
not had since
1973 but on the on the flip side of that
pokemony might leave the country
yes
the roe vs wade
news is
absolutely terrible
i tweeted about it irt a couple things i
faved a couple things it's just tough
because
[Music]
what more can we even say at this point
we've said it all
it's depressing
i booked a ticket back to canada like
anna
no
pokemony
you're going back to canada no how can
you
first question just before we move on
who is pokemony i don't know i saw this
headline come up i had not heard of
pokemony i had heard of pokemon the the
japanese cartoon but i had not heard of
pokemony she is a twitch streamer
and not only is she a twitch streamer
she is not american
she is from my very modest googling
she is moroccan
and canadian
but she's in america right now and she's
very upset by the dobbs decision to save
the babies and why is she upset she
can't quite articulate it she says what
is there to say for someone like
pokemony probably there's not quite a
lot to say and she says i'm i'm going
back to canada
okay
all right
i think that's fine
why
why do i care what pokemony thinks i
certainly don't even further
why should i care
what a moroccan canadian thinks about
my laws
why should i care about that and why
should i care that this
foreign twitch streamer is now going to
leave my country because she's so angry
that we're not going to kill quite so
many babies
why why should her opinion have any
effect on me whatsoever
it does not she has influence with some
people but not with me she's not the
only foreigner who's weighing in
on this issue
we've we've got uh mr macron emmanuel
macron the leader of france who
is very upset about the supreme court's
decision in dobbs for some reason and he
tweeted out quote abortion is a
fundamental right for all women it must
be protected i wish to express my
solidarity with the women whose
liberties are being undermined by the
supreme court of the united states
now the irony there's there's so many
layers of irony to macron's statement
but the top line is
in france abortions are only allowed for
any reason
up until 14 weeks
up until 14 weeks the law in america the
mississippi law that brought the dobbs
decision to overrule roe v wade to let
the states make their own abortion laws
the the mississippi law
bans abortions after 15 weeks
abortion is more restricted in france
than it is
in mississippi which is the center point
of this case and yet macron ways this is
terrible what you americans are doing
you are getting rid you are making your
your abortion laws almost as restrictive
as ours are this is a fundamental right
abortion obviously it's not a
fundamental right but even if it were
america would be even in mississippi
would be protecting that right more than
more than macron is
denmark's prime minister mitte
fredrickson mitte says my heart weeps
for the girl i'm not going to do a
danish impression i just don't have my
danish accent is not quite so good
my heart weeps for the girls and women
of the us whenever i don't have an
accent i just do jordan peterson my
heart weeps for the girls and women of
the usa a huge setback the right to a
free abortion is one of the most
fundamental rights there is
well they're really escalating the
rhetoric it's not just abortion safe
legal and rare every abortion's a
tragedy but we have to permit it for
some reason then it became no abortions
a right now it's abortions
one of the most fundamental rights there
is
life is the most fundamental right there
is without the right to life no other
rights can possibly exist now the libs
are inverting that they're saying
the right quote unquote to kill your own
child is one of the most fundamental
rights does that seem coherent to you
not to me she goes we must never
compromise
the unrestricted right of women to
decide over their own bodies and future
you know the irony here layers and
layers of irony you probably are
guessing it
in denmark
unrestricted abortion is only allowed up
to 12 weeks
the danish laws on abortion are much
more restrictive than the mississippi
law
it's so
ignorant it's they just don't
either they don't know
what our laws are the laws that they're
weighing in on and pontificating on
or
they just want to hold us to a different
standard than they are holding
themselves
the one good thing here
outside of the ignorance and presumption
of
of macron and this and frederickson
is
it shows you just how important the
dobbs decision is
because the dobbs decision doesn't just
affect america because america isn't
just a nation america is in fact an
empire
and everyone around if you've ever
traveled around the world especially
near an american election you will know
that
virtually every other country on earth
treats the american election as very
important to their own countries
treats the american election as though
they are part of an american empire
because in many ways they are and so
when america does something like this
when america radically changes course
and says you know we're not we're not
going to outlaw abortion unfortunately
just yet but we are going to
restrict abortion and allow the people
to make their own abortion restrictions
that has reverberations outside of just
the united states
that that has reverberations throughout
the world even just in the fact that
america in its foreign policy now will
be more reined in in promoting abortion
because there is no national right to an
abortion there is no constitutional
right to an abortion
speaking of foreigners another big win
from the supreme court not the u.s
supreme court but the new york supreme
court which just yesterday ruled that a
law in new york city allowing
non-citizens to vote
is unconstitutional
and it's not unconstitutional according
to the u.s constitution it's
unconstitutional according to the new
york state constitution this was judge
ralph porzio
of the new york supreme court for long
island ruled that the city violated the
state constitution which says that every
citizen is entitled to vote
but if you're not a citizen you are not
entitled to vote this is a big deal
the law allowed an estimated 800 000 to
1 million
non-citizens illegal aliens living in
new york city
uh to
to vote
and i should be even more precise with
my language here it's not just that this
law was aimed at allowing people who
cross the border illegally from latin
america to vote but we're talking about
non-citizens who have legal status we're
talking about non-citizens who have a
green card but they're not citizens
the the law would have allowed them to
vote in the city elections
there are only 6.7 million people voting
age in new york city
so then you're going to allow another
million people who are foreigners to
vote
obviously that is going to swing
elections
and the court came in and said no you
don't have the right to do that we are
going to protect
our elections we are going to protect
our people we are going to protect our
sovereignty we are we're we're going to
have a real country guys
that's been the takeaway from the past
couple of weeks
you get to practice your religion
some woke lunatic isn't going to tell
you no you get to exercise your second
amendment rights some woke lunatic isn't
going to tell you no we're going to
protect our babies we're not going to
tolerate killing a million babies a year
upwards of a million babies a year just
because the libs want us to
we are going to protect the integrity of
our election we're going to have a real
country folks
and that's really really great news
now speaking of foreigners there there
is another aspect to all of this which
is not getting a ton of play in the
media but we should
we should mention it now so that when
when tragic events come to pass we will
at least have predicted them
all of this consternation that
everyone's talking about all of the
rancorous debates in our country over
the court decisions is giving up the
perfect timing
to this news story
gelane maxwell is on suicide watch
now you know tomorrow we've got
backstage live coming to the ryman
auditorium the historic ryman auditorium
in nashville if you haven't seen it in
person take a listen
welcome to the daily wire backstage live
at the famous ryman auditorium
it was amazing we were in the presence
of greatness the energy of having
everyone on the same page was amazing if
your family member is still waiting for
fauci to give them permission to leave
their house it might be time to cut that
off
i'm actually pretty excited to meet all
of them i love everybody's opinion
individually i don't have a favorite i
like them all i had found out a way to
make football players cry in high school
my high school experience
i'm just excited to be here and be
surrounded by like-minded people and to
just you know feel that energy who
should we remove from office yeah one
politician the most powerful politician
in the country dr fauci
we're doing culture here i'm so thrilled
to see this happening if they say to
half of the country you can't that half
of the country needs to say screw you we
will
head on over to dailywire.com
knowles right now get 25 off your new
membership today that's
dailywire.com and you can tune in and
stream backstage live at the ryman
auditorium tomorrow 8 p.m eastern to
find out what's next we have some pretty
big stuff coming down the pike we'll be
right back with a lot more
i'm pretty sure hillary clinton has
already sent her condolences on the
future suicide of elaine maxwell it's so
sad that she will have killed herself
very soon
gillian maxwell the
romantic and business partner of jeffrey
epstein procurer of young girls madam
for creepypedo island
gilain maxwell has been placed on
suicide watch
she is therefore prohibited from
reviewing legal materials prior to her
sentencing for uh for her crimes
she is not being permitted to meet with
her counsel
she will be formally moving on uh monday
for an
adjournment
this is according to her attorney bobby
sternheim
according to the attorney this is what's
really weird
elaine maxwell is being placed on
suicide watch despite
not being suicidal
it's according to the attorney and the
psychologist who evaluated maxwell
backed up that assessment according to
reuters
so gelane maxwell says she's not
suicidal her attorney says she's not
suicidal a psychologist that
independently came in and assessed her
says she's not suicidal but
the government says she's suicidal and
so she's going to have all these new
restrictions placed on her and
hope she's okay
hope a couple cameras don't go out hope
those guards don't accidentally sleep
through their duty while hillary just
sneaks in the back and chokes the
ever-loving life out of her with her own
bare hands and then walks out into
groucho classes or something and never
is elaine heard from again
i don't know if elaine maxwell will be
suicided or not
or you know if she's just really
secretly depressed and will off herself
the only thing i would point out from a
political perspective
if
someone means to do elaine maxwell harm
if for instance elaine maxwell has
extremely damaging blackmail on the most
powerful people on earth and she almost
she alone has it
uh this would be a good time to offer
because everyone is focused on
everything else everyone is focused on
the repeal of or the overturning rather
of roe v wade this is the most important
supreme court development on one of the
most contentious social issues in 50
years
that would be a good time
the end of the term the fireworks from
the supreme court you've got the midterm
elections coming up you've got this
crazy economy a war in the middle east
there's a lot going on in the news that
could distract people
if
certain influential people or
institutions or corrupt politicians or
whoever
want to want to off elaine maxwell i'm
calling it now
gaelane maxwell did not kill herself
speaking of weird sex stuff
there was a there have been a number of
protests of the dobbs decisions
uh politicians screaming young women
protesting with babies and fake blood
and things like that
women in dallas took a different tack
they protested the dobbs decision
by by twerking
everywhere in public
[Applause]
a lot of twerking it seems to all be
women
we're generally sort of androgynous
people they're all twerking on each
other
[Applause]
my
my body my choice
people were kind of rolling on the
ground and shaking
and jiggling
there were various screams and cries of
the sort of you know [ __ ] walk chants
you forget about i don't want to be a
mother down with the patriarchy i'm a
i'm a proud [ __ ] and a hoe and all that
kind of stuff
my only take on these protests
the ladies if they want to twerk i
suppose they can twerk my only take on
the protests is if you are just a normal
person right and you don't pay a ton of
attention to politics and you you're not
a pro-life advocate
going out in the street praying rosaries
in front of planned parenthoods and
you're not a pro-choice activist a
pro-abortion activist who's going out
there and
and making your voice heard if you're
just a kind of ordinary person in the
middle who goes about your daily life
and goes to work and takes care of your
family and you see this
and you see that
is that going to convince you to join
their cause
i don't think so
i don't think it will
the the women who are going out there
and jiggling and twerking and screaming
i think they misunderstand
what ordinary people want i don't think
that ordinary people want to be just
degenerate promiscuous
degenerates they're i guess it's a
little redundant but i don't think
that's what most people aspire to be
and even if the twerking in the protest
is ironic they seem to believe that the
conservatives are are trying to protect
babies just because we hate women or we
or we hate sexuality or we we're really
if you look at
pro-life people
you'll notice they tend to have a lot of
kids
they're not they're not sex negative
okay they're pretty sex-positive they
just realize that sex is supposed to
exist within certain constraints the
fact that sex is so very important to
our nature which the libs have been
telling us for so so long and that's
behind the transgender movement that's
behind the whole rainbow movement
they're saying sex is so important that
we've got to take it very seriously
that's what the pro-lifers are saying
they're saying yes sex is very very
important
and it's a very powerful force and it
can go off the rails like those ladies
in dallas are showing you and so we've
got to make sure it remains within
certain confines so that it can be
ordered in the right way and we can
channel that and don't end up like them
i hope these women keep twerking i think
every time one of these women jiggles we
get another pro-life activist every time
someone sees one of these people shaking
around we're going to get another
republican vote in november
the libs are very upset at this idea of
limiting
our sexual desires and behaviors
business insider i think they've
rebranded just to insider
this is a very far left-wing
news outlet they're very upset that gen
z right now
is
going to be having less sex actually gen
z doesn't have a lot of sex they have
very open promiscuous views on sex but
they have less real life actual sex than
previous generations headlines swearing
off men and avoiding intimacy gen z
reconsiders sex in the wake of a
post-row world
madeline v might be done with men
altogether a 24 year old marketing
assistant who identifies as bisexual
madeleine who asked that insider only
use her first name has decided that
sticking to female partners may be the
safest sexual route these days it's not
a fear of men exactly that has inspired
this young woman to consider swearing
off an entire gender it's the heightened
fear of unwanted pregnancy and a
subsequent lack of options that has
forced madeline to proceed with sexual
caution in the wake of friday's supreme
court decision gutting federal abortion
rights protections
right so so insider this left-wing
outlet is is writing this
as though this should be horrifying to
everybody
it's just like those people at the top
of the show
here and this is it's not that she fears
and hates men
it's that she doesn't she doesn't want
to have an unwanted pregnancy if she's
not allowed to kill her child so now
she's going to be a little more sexually
cautious
great good good good that's sort of the
point
that's good for the baby obviously the
baby who will not be killed through
abortion
but it's good it's good for society that
we won't have this sexual chaos
everywhere but it's good for madeleine
it's good for madeleine too
does anybody still seriously believe
years after me too years after
the the
enough is enough movement
does anyone seriously believe that
hookup culture is really really good for
women the the article goes on
i wish i could read the entire article
for you they say
quoting quoting a young woman
surprisingly enough i've actually had
dreams where i'm pregnant and i can't
find a way to take care of myself
adeline said correcting herself saying
the visions were more akin to nightmares
she can't find a way to take care of
herself
what about a um
a husband
have you thought if you become pregnant
it's probably not going to happen
because you know you sit on a toilet
seat if you become pregnant it's going
to happen because you have sex with
somebody what if hear me out i know this
is crazy what if you do
what
everyone did throughout all of human
history until about 40 years ago and
marry that person and then you don't you
don't need to worry about just taking
care of yourself you will have a husband
who will go out and make money for you
and provide food and shelter for you and
you can raise the family and you can you
can do some work yourself as well but
you won't have to carry that whole
whole heavy load yourself you'll have
what something that's called a family
so family this is an old-fashioned
concept it existed
well as recently as i don't know a
couple decades ago but a family is when
people come together in something called
a marriage
and a marriage i know we've we've
changed all the definitions and nothing
means anything anymore but a marriage is
when a man and a woman come together and
they love each other ideally and then
they produce a child like you're saying
you know
well that part would have come first but
whatever that's okay and you come
together and then you live together and
you can even make more children and you
can have a good life if you want or or
you can just continue to live alone in a
sort of miserable isolated alienated
existence working for some other guy at
a company another guy who doesn't care
about you and will throw you under the
bus the second that you're no longer
profitable to him and you instead of
sleeping with
a hundred different men none of whom
care about you at all
you can just sleep with your husband and
instead of killing your own children you
can actually give birth to them and
raise them and have a loving wonderful
existence
i know it's radical and crazy i'm not
i'm being obviously somewhat somewhat uh
humorous here in the way i'm describing
it but i actually think people probably
do need to hear it i actually think that
the younger generations who have been
raised in the madness of the sexual
revolution and in the wake of the sexual
revolution probably don't think about
these things all that much because the
hook-up culture is just
it's just ubiquitous it's just the way
that things are
the idea of getting married young and
staying married and having kids and
having a good life it's it's a foreign
concept
frankly it was it was
a somewhat foreign concept even when i
was a teenager growing up in liberal
places i can't even imagine now
ever since the draft decision was leaked
adeline has had to entirely rethink
whether or not she wants to start having
sex telling insider that she's terrified
to make a choice that could leave her
with an unwanted child good catherine
said she's been left to re-evaluate the
consequences of casual sex that have
suddenly become very real
awesome great she says as much as i want
to have fun in my 20s what happens to me
when the fun stops what happens to me
when i might be in need of an abortion
and can't access that
what happens when the fun stops great
question to ask yourself
in hookup culture if you're just hooking
up you don't just bring up that stuff
right away normally
she said but when it comes to if you're
actually going to sleep with someone i
think at this point that definitely
needs to be addressed
this is really great stuff
the hookup culture is terrible for
everyone it's very enticing it's very
tempting i know it seems fun at the time
but ultimately it's not fun and it makes
everybody miserable
it's also probably the primary driver of
the rape culture
hysteria that was going on in in recent
years and the metoo movement and all of
that none of that would have been
possible without a culture that
encouraged promiscuous sex obviously
rape would still happen but the idea of
a rape culture this pervasive endemic
sort of men exploiting women and
pressuring women and harvey weinstein
saying come on up to my hotel suite and
these drunken rendezvous that occur all
over colleges and bars where consent is
very unclear and and the lines that
people want to to engage in their their
blurred lines
none of that would be possible without
the sexual revolution and a culture of
promiscuous sex
and the consequences of that have been
disastrous especially for women but the
main reason i want to bring up this
article
is not even all of that it's to remind
conservatives of a very important truth
namely
culture
very often is downstream of politics you
know andrew breitbart had that famous
line politics is downstream of culture
which is true in as much as the movies
matter and the press matters and books
matter and
private civic associations matter yeah
that's all true
but
politics is downstream of culture is a
slogan and like all slogans it cannot
convey the
whole of
reality and if it's if
politics is downstream of culture is
taken to its extreme
it's nothing more than an excuse for
conservatives and libertarians to ignore
the political order and actual
government
and the power that the people happily
give us on occasion
culture can be downstream of politics
too
the example that i frequently use is
east and west germany
the german east germany was was
conquered by the soviet union for the
latter half of the 20th century west
germany remained
free remained part of the west
west germany
has very high rates of people who
believe in god today
east germany is almost entirely atheist
why is that is that because of regional
variations in rot wurst and bavarian
donuts
no it's because east germany was
dominated by an officially atheist
regime for 40 years
that's why
these these women are showing you this
right now they're saying gosh you know
when the law was a certain way
i i engaged in this kind of behavior in
my private life
but now that the law is different i'm
going to i'm going to behave in a
different way this is something that we
have known throughout all of history and
that somehow conservatives and
libertarians forgot for the last 30 or
40 years but the law is a teacher
the law shapes society
conservatives and libertarians
especially are so good at understanding
incentives but we seem to forget that
when it comes to the law when you create
legal incentives
for certain behaviors you get more of
them when you create legal disincentives
for certain behaviors you get less of
them
the incentives and disincentives created
by dobbs are absolutely magnificent and
we should double down on it
have much more pro-life legislation
throughout the states it will not only
be good for the babies though it
obviously will be
it will be good for everyone involved
speaking of the birds and the bees
there was a lib blue check carrie go
skosh i don't know haven't haven't heard
of her before
she
tweeted out something that i think
really typifies the
misunderstanding and misinformation
going around the dobbs case she said
reporters and editors
reporters and editors it is not a fetal
heartbeat
at six weeks
it is cardiac activity no organ has
formed in an embryo it's not a fetal
heartbeat
stop reporting on these laws that
protect life after there is a fetal
heartbeat it's not a fetal heartbeat
it's cardiac activity in an embryo and
cardiac of course is a synonym for heart
so it's a it's heart it's a heart active
it's a heartbeat in an embryo which is a
synonym for a fetus so it's a heartbeat
in a fetus and and by the way fetus is
just the latin word for offspring for
child so what's the difference
what's amazing this woman
she said it's not
it would be like saying hey hey hey
reporters
stop reporting on on submarine
sandwiches
stop stop reporting on a delicious
italian sub it's an italian hoagie it's
a it's not that's not an italian sub
that's a that's a
calabrese hoagie
you say uh well i know you're using
different words but the words are
referring to the same
thing and the libs have to change all
the words this is the uh topic of my
book number one national best-selling
speechless controlling words gonna play
mines thank you to all of you who went
out and bought it this is the topic of
of my book the libs
because the facts run against their
arguments the only recourse they are
left with is to change the words and
hope that people get confused
and sometimes the a real problem for the
libs is that they believe their own
euphemisms
they forget the purpose of those
euphemisms which is to to deceive people
and they end up deceiving themselves
they violate one of the most important
rules it was the best advice my mother
ever gave me when i was a young
boy and i was becoming very cocky
because i'd gotten a good grade on a an
exam or something and she said michael
don't believe your own press releases
that's very good advice don't believe
your own press releases the libs are
believing their own press releases they
are high on their own
supply and it's a political detriment to
them because
they're actually not fooling anyone else
they're no they're no longer fooling the
supreme court they're no longer fooling
the majority of americans if you look at
polling
they only appear to be fooling
themselves and the more they change the
words they more the more they seem to
babble incoherently
hence you get well actually before i
even get to our vice president i do want
to get to our vice president but before
i get to her i have to read this poem
from
probably the most prominent poet in
america right now this is that that
young girl who spoke at joe biden's
inauguration
this is probably the most praised lauded
feted poet in america right now she has
1.6 million twitter followers here is
her take on the dobbs decision
i have to i have to try to not laugh
while i read this
we will not be
delayed we will not be
masquerade
to the tale of a hand made
we will not let roe v wade slowly fade
because when we show up today
we're already standing up
with the tomorrow we made
let's get to work and then it's a link
to some pro-abortion thing
not exactly wordsworth
not uh
not not shakespeare here is it
one at a grammatical level
we will not be masquerade
this woman doesn't know what the word
masquerade means
a masquerade is a a noun
you uh or or a verb you can you can
masquerade as someone else
you cannot
be masquerade so she doesn't know what
that word is she then misspells handmade
she spells it
h-a-n-d-m-a-d-e not m-a-i-d and then she
rhymes made with made
with the same spelling
not
not very uh great poetry
then she follows it up she says
pregnancy is a private and personal
decision it should never require the
permission of any politician
um
she's not a poet and she don't even even
know it but also just the claim she's
making at the top pregnancy is a private
and personal decision it's not it's not
whatever you think about abortion you
can't say it's a private and personal
matter pregnancy by definition involves
another person that's what makes it
pregnancy it is pregnancy because it
involves a baby
if it doesn't involve a baby then it's
then i don't then it's just you have
some growth in you you have a polyp or
something what makes it a pregnancy is
the other person
completely incoherent and the libs
gobble this up they don't know what it
means the poet doesn't know what it
means they don't really
have any interest in finding out what
things mean they just
go with the flow of the things that
sound nice and they're they're not
exercising their higher levels of
thinking which is which is why they're
getting out foxed right now it's sort of
fine by me kamala harris our intrepid
vice president
was just asked hey
the number one issue for voters is not
abortion
it's not the dobbs decision it's not
religious liberty
it's the economy and inflation what are
you guys doing about inflation and
recession
now
inflation is is really high are you
concerned about a recession the
administration said
that they weren't that worried about the
about inflation and then
that changed i think that
there can be no higher priority
than what we have been clear is our
highest priority which is bringing down
the cost and the prices as much as we
possibly can and we will stay focused on
it
kamala harris i think is doing her
impression of that poet there can be no
higher priority than what is our pr uh
is our priority and is the handmade and
the way in the v and that
she's she's just
repeating the question
she's just repeating the
she's
making the first part of her statement
there can be no higher priority than
and then she just repeat what is our
highest priority
sort of tautological isn't it isn't that
a truism yes it's true there can be no
higher priority than what is their
highest priority but they can't
articulate what the highest priority is
and i think it's because they don't know
they don't have any answers it is a
failure of understanding it's not even
this isn't just me throwing bombs
calling these people idiots they might
be idiots but that's that's sort of
beside the point
they simply
do not get even what the question is
right now they do not get what is
motivating conservatives they do not
understand what is motivating the
opposition to them and so if they don't
get that part they're certainly not
going to be able to figure out how to
solve anything
or how to beat us and that's fine by me
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knolls show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire